December c-span is airing for the first
time on television selected interviews
from the Richard Nixon Presidential
Library
oral history project in this
conversation with Sir David Frost
library director Timothy Naphtali talks
with the journalists about how the
famous 1977 frost Nixon interviews
unfolded the behind-the-scenes
negotiations and his own recollections
of the former president this interview
is about 30 minutes my name is Tim
Naftali I'm a director of the pret
Richard Nixon Presidential Library
Museum
it's October 30th 2007
we're in Washington DC and I have the
privilege and honor to be interviewing
Sir David Frost for our rural History
Program Sir David thank you for joining
us it's a pleasure to be with you
pleasure to me sir David please tell us
about your meeting with Jack Brennan who
was President Nixon's former President
Nixon's chief of staff when you were
discussing the nature of the interview
one that we wanted to of those which one
will you think you know I was thinking
of the one where you talk about
arithmetics arithmetic yes this was this
was very tense we were we were afraid
that they were trying to delay things
beyond the possible point to an
impossible point and so pressing for
them to move they were worried about our
editing and all of that sort of thing
and defending Nixon Jack Brennan said
listen 60% of what that man did was
great was really good 30% may not have
been good but he did not realize that
well mathematicians watching us now this
moment in history will realize that that
left 10% which were not good and he must
have realized they were not good all
were wrong or whatever and that was an
early an amazing sort of
seismic thought but then he pressed you
yes and he said and he said and if you
if you don't do justice to the 60% then
I will never forgive you I will pursue
you I will pursue you to ruin and I said
and if you screw us on the 10% I will do
the same to you and that was that was a
tense situation between the two of us
and there was one other session which I
didn't know whether you meant which was
when he had been a little bit slow in
some of his answers not not mentally
slow but just just not not filibustering
but just took longer and so although we
had 24 hours it didn't seem like enough
and so I took Jack Brennan out to lunch
at the quiet cannon I think it was cool
and I said we really need another four
hours not 24 but 28 hours and and we
don't we don't have any money left to
pay for it and so he said I don't know
we can do that and then I said because
you know if we don't get that extra four
hours you know there we're just going to
have to drop some subjects like China
and of course we got the extra four
hours it was actually a nick Sounion
tactic played on mix-ins man perhaps
there was also there was also a moment
where Frank Frank Gannon played a role
in resolving an issue yes he he he
really engaging guy he'd he'd worked I
met him before he worked as a researcher
from Randolph Churchill and he was known
there as the pudding boy why was he
known as the pudding Walker cars
yet pudding after pudding after pudding
or dessert after dessert after dessert
but the pudding boy oh it's the pudding
boy as but but Frank very very bright
guy and one of these stages is key
stages in the timing of the Watergate
session and the fact that it had to be
done by a certain date in order to get
on the air in time and so I'm am and I
mean it was very complicated there were
even more complications probably than
even in in my book because I mean there
were delays there were lawyers there
were worries that that as long as
almonds trials were not over then he
couldn't talk about them and I mean it
was it was a really complex complex
period and that's and that's when the
tensions were there hi later on I mean
Jack Brennan you know became a good
friend and and and the team's work
together like like friendly legal teams
for the oral history I'd like you to
document if you will the conversation
that you had with Henry Kissinger and to
tell us where it happened
the one where he responds after you've
interviewed Nixon on foreign policy
matters well what happened was that the
one of the most humorous parts of the
Nixon interviews was undoubtedly
whenever Richard Nixon talked about
Henry Kissinger because obviously these
two men were umbilical a linked in terms
of credit from history and they couldn't
afford to snag each other off because
then the other might like them and it
would might affect their joint
reputation or there's so many reputation
or whatever so they both wanted to go
for the for the top billing and the
responsibility for the good things and
somehow slough off the bad things and so
on and so forth and so Nixon would
pursue this policy of saying oh Henry as
he said so bad
Henry was so he was so in terms of him
he's a real he was a real intellectual
there was a real intellectual I mean and
and you know like most intellectuals you
know he was you know unstable and like
miss infectious you know unreliable and
you know and you couldn't be sure he'd
stick with the point of view like he
wanted us to change our policy on Kent
State and and after Kent State and after
that had happened that we should go back
and change our policy on Cambodia and
and I had just I had to say to him
remember Lot's wife never look back
Henry never looked back them so that was
his approach to Henry and I was speaking
to Henry Kissinger on the phone the week
we'd done this interview and he said oh
I you you've been I've been you've been
giving me this week he said I spent I
spent mix and describe me as a sort
unreliable intellectual who needed his
strong and sturdy hand and I said Henry
have you been bugging these sessions and
he said no David I just know my boy I
just know my boy and and and the
corollary to that was Henry's way of of
striking back as I said he couldn't
strike back directly because there they
were linked by history so his way of it
was more or less to say President Nixon
was a great president he's
underestimated it's terrible ways
underestimated he was a great delegator
that was the great thing and and you
know he he delegated most of the
important things to me of course but but
he was a great you know and that was
that was you have a chance to interview
sir I mean Henry Kissinger is a long
story that I did an interview with with
him in for the first volume of his
memoirs NBC felt they had NBC had signed
a controversial contract with him
whereby everybody criticized it because
they said you can't have Henry as an
independent commentator because he's
obviously going to commentate on things
been good that he
and things that that someone else is
doing it's not so good I mean you know
this is not so they wanted to find an
independent interrogator and this was
two years after two years after the
Nixon interviews when Henry had said
that he thought the program on foreign
policy was terrific
and this this one became a real a real
confrontation and we we scarcely spoke
for twenty years and I mean and it was
really tense and so we didn't really
capture we we captured some very
powerful stuff but we didn't we didn't
obviously get the relaxed Henry the the
anecdotal Henry to that extent because
the thing was rather was rather tense
but it but it made for a a very dramatic
program did you use the entire program
or was it edited well what happened was
that the the this was an NBC news
program so it wasn't my production so
they brought me in asked me to do this
which which they rarely did so that was
a compliment and so on but it was their
program so that I had to resign from the
program because they wanted me to redo
some of the questions and so then they
had to finish the program and luckily
they did finish it and it was very I
cannot tell you how lonely it was to
know that the program of yours was being
edited and you were not doing it for
four or five days but they but they did
do it and it did go out and it it's a I
remembered feeling it had all been
worthwhile to stand firm on these voice
because John J O'Connor wrote a thing in
the New York Times with the day after it
went out that was you know somehow made
all the agony worthwhile when you were
editing or thinking about editing the
Nixon interviews in your book you say
that a lot of the a number of the first
minutes of conversation you thought
would just go into the toilet that you
were disappointed
was not as you had hoped particularly
the discussion the agent half minute gap
give us a little bit of sense a sense of
the evolution of the interview your
confidence in the interview as it
progressed yes it was really the 89 -
and the the first the first program the
first day we we've been trying to decide
what to do is the first particular day
and and we ended up with a bit of a
hodgepodge really and it was the second
day when we started getting really
serious about Vietnam that one realized
that we were on to firmer ground I mean
that Vietnam material I mean we went
over to great lengths and in in in my
book there is you know there's 50 or 60
pages and and Nixon I mean particularly
Nixon being of course above everything
else passionate about the fact that it
was the Congress that lost Vietnam I
mean that was that was the thing he
cared about saying most of all I think
that that the the brief period when his
his peace plan survived from 73 to 75
was destroyed purely by him by the
Congress and not by anybody else and but
so that was the subject that that really
triggered us off in the fact that now we
are now we're focusing and now we're
getting somewhere
one of the other things that of course
you won't have to be very careful of
that is we had a very good girl woman
called Jennifer Chou who who did the
transcripts every day and we were doing
sessions on Monday Wednesday and Friday
so she overnight on the Monday would
produce a transcript so when we watch
the program the further previous day's
program we had a transcript and
transcripts up they were almost always
perfect but we came upon one that we
couldn't remember
what he meant Nixon said and then of
course I withdrew fifty thousand men
from Vietnam after I met you at Midway
you know I remember him saying it and I
certainly know I was never in Midway so
we went back to the tape and of course
what he had actually said was after I
met to it Midway you know but but it's a
sort of thing that could slip into a
transcript and slip out but you were
responsible for Vietnamization that tell
us in the in the play there is a sense
and I suppose in the movie too that
there was some disappointment in the in
the frost team as you neared the
Watergate interview tell me about tell
us about the role that the transcripts
and the other materials played in
briefing you to what extent did you
think you were on top of this you had
what you needed
well I felt by the time we got to the
stage that I really knew that knew the
transcripts as well as it was possible
to know or all the transcripts were
available including those ones that
James Reston and discovered that were
available but nobody had spotted them
before and I really felt confident in
that sense and that was a confidence
that grew over the grew over the period
the the the anguish in the potential
anguish in the minds of the team in is
built up a lot in in the play in the
film probably because because it's
important to the drama and so on as as
Peter Morgan always says patiently
sighing to me you know David this is a
play not a documentary or sometimes he
said this is a documentary not a by
either way around but but the but so
that he he lays it on a bit thick they
were they were concerned and I think
when you actually read again what what
what Bob's only said about the qualities
of Richard Nixon just before this
session that's in the book as I did just
before you do realize what a daunting
task it was and we you know I mean the
list of the things he served as a lawyer
for this he's done in the death a ton of
the dirt that that I mean it's really
daunting list and and we were daunted in
that sense and I was daunted in that
sense but but I I never lost my faith
that we or I was going to pull it off
before this interview for which
interview do you think you had done the
greatest amount of preparation and what
was the hardest interview before this
Richard Nixon interview Vietnam I
suppose because there's so much of
Vietnam no I know I mean a person other
than Richard Nixon was it oh I see I see
mr. McMillan did you interview McMillan
no I he'd he'd by the time I was
interviewing he'd sort of given up given
up interview being I would say that's a
very interesting
I mean in a concentrated sense possibly
general Norman Schwarzkopf because they
interview we did immediately immediately
after the Gulf War part 1 was was a
crucial one and have headlines for four
days and front-page headlines for four
days and so on and and that involved a
lot of research sometimes sometimes
going to countries that for the first
time involves the first time I
interviewed Gough Whitlam about to be
the Prime Minister of Australia involved
a lot of work because I didn't the first
time I interviewed
fika Ali Bhutto of Pakistan and the
father of the executed father of Benazir
Bhutto they were the most difficult
interview however was I was launching
I'd agreed with Nana we came to go to
Finland not to Finland it was to Norway
and Sweden to promote that series call
frost insanity which was a more
lighthearted program which was going out
on the air both so we we did a press
conference in Norway in the morning and
in the afternoon we did a session in
Sweden then it was only five o'clock and
so I said well planes not to 7:00 so we
can be down have a drink at the hotel
and they they said no no no you gotta
give away straight away to the studios
for your live interview with the Deputy
Prime Minister I said I never heard in
all the papers here listed in all the
papers that I was into it he was in at
that time an unknown man he he became
very well known as Olaf Alma but but he
was absolutely unknown to me at that
time I couldn't have told you what party
he was in or anything I knew nothing
about him and I was supposed to
interview him in half an hour and so on
the way to the studio I was making a
list of all the questions that I could
ask that
that I didn't know the answers but I
mean it just were general question what
do you regard is your greatest
achievement I mean he could have said it
he could have claimed to have walked on
water you know but I wouldn't know where
he died what's your greatest achievement
what's your biggest mistake if you were
to look at the map of the world in ten
years time in what ways would it differ
from today and so on and so forth and by
the time it's nightmare I bet I'm I got
to the studio I've got 12 or 15 of these
generalist questions and we got through
the interview we had enough to get
through the interview we did the
interview and to profit for the airport
with a sigh of relief and the joke was
that the Stockholm papers the next day
were unanimous and they all said how
refreshing to have an interviewer who
does not trouble himself with the
minutiae of
day-to-day politics and instead
concentrates on the great issues of our
time see you're preparing for Watergate
after these interviews Bob Zoellick says
to the press that this in a sense was
the trial of Richard Nixon when did you
realize that you actually would have the
opportunity to cross-examine a man who
because of the pardon had never been
cross-examined before about Watergate
and and how did you think about this new
responsibility as as a Brit indeed
absolutely that was because of the
because of the pardon and and also
because of the phlebitis I suppose for
both reasons he'd never been questioned
on these matters and so that was yes
that was foremost in my mind from the
very beginning that this was a real
responsibility that it was the first and
it might be the only time as it has in
fact it turned out to be and so that was
very much in our mind from the very word
view of that responsibility and and that
challenge to please tell us about
because
people will see in the film tell us
about how the break occurred in the
first Watergate session the pause that
that break in the first that's very
interesting because that break was was
obviously unplanned and initially
misconstrued by myself because we were
approaching the the vital last 15-20
minutes of the of the interview we'd
been through a lot of the mistakes we'd
been through Haldeman and Ehrlichman 's
Damis or aster and so on and Nixon was
starting to give even more than he ever
had up until that point and suddenly I
saw Jack Brennan his chief of staff come
into the room with it with a sign which
as far as I can see said let us talk
he's never been in before
well this is interesting we have a quick
tape stop and find out so I said we just
got to change the tapes and so on and as
he came closer I realized that he did
didn't in fact say let us draw it said
let him talk so in other words he was
pressing for the fact that I not
continued too much of an interrogation
that might chamonix or that because he
thought Nixon was was on the verge of
having more things to say that he'd
never said before so Jack Brennan and
that was on the side of the Angels at
that particular moment in reality
equally dramatic in the pray is a
different scenario where Jack Brennan
sees Nixon about to give
and wants to get hold of him for a
minute just not necessarily to shut him
up but at least to make him aware of
what he's on the verge of doing so
Brennan comes in interrupts the everyone
gets angry and he interrupts to
basically say I want to talk to come
with me as it were and and he takes
Nixon out and says that the two versions
both dramatic one true and one not true
but had different motions really because
Jack Brennan seemed to be trying to slow
Nixon down in the play whereas he seemed
to be encouraging me to let Nixon role
in the actual real real version in your
in your writing about this you say that
you were a little worried that after
this remarkable moment he had reached
the president reached a point of
vulnerability that you could not get him
to again but you do in the second
Watergate interview how do you do that
well fortunately the first interview of
the two days on Watergate was such a
disaster for him because he was not
admitting anything that's more not
admitting anything and his people who
had said that they could never brief him
in advance because Watergate was too was
too personal just to deeper hurt to
personal must have in some way got their
point across to Nixon that this total
stonewall was doomed doomed to failure
and perhaps even ignominy and when he
came on the second day first of all he
was late 18 minutes late not 18 and a
half minutes late that would have been
too poetic but the but and and he looked
he looked rather like he did on during
the days of the actual Watergate
Watergate thing taking place and and so
he came on the second day and
obviously either worked out I never
found out the answer this either worked
out talking with his age who suddenly
decided they had to talk to her about
Watergate even though it was so painful
or on his own he had worked out that he
had to go further so it so what made the
second day work after the first day was
the fact that the first day was such a
disaster for him and he realized it
because I knew the tapes as well a bit
of them he did and point after point and
particularly really the 16 or 17 points
about John Dean mentioning money on all
the conversation between Nixon and Dean
mentioning money those had such potency
that that he therefore it was the it was
the very non community of nature of the
first day that made the second day
possible even perhaps inevitable do you
feel that the these on to that point
unused transcripts the James Reston had
found that they were the ones that
helped push him over the edge
they were the unused transcripts were
very helpful but but they were not that
important because there were two days on
Watergate to two and a half hours for
each and these tapes came in the first
hour really first hour of day one
and so it was for four and a half hours
later in television terms when he
started to crumple to give in or
whatever what do you recall of your
reaction when he asked you to suggest a
better word than mistakes to substitute
for in this case that was the most
heart-stopping answer I've ever had
because I knew that he was more
vulnerable at that moment than he
probably ever would be again and that I
must phrase my response in order to get
that get that across and I threw down my
clipboard in order to indicate that this
was not a
scripted job that this was not prepared
ambush or anything like this this was a
moment that neither of us had ever
expected what would happen and then I
phrased the I chose tried to say I said
there seems to me there are three things
the American people want you to say and
not to hear and the first is that that
there was wrongdoing in the White House
maybe criminality indeed that secondly
you let down your whole out of office
and thirdly that you put the American
people through two years of needless
pain and you apologize for that and I
said that's difficult for anybody and I
know it's particularly difficult for you
but if you don't do it I think you'll be
haunted for the rest of your life and
that's when he took the three points
remembered the three points and dealt
with the three points over the next 20
minutes leading to that fine what you
think I'm gonna have to run another hit
last two question when that was done you
what what what do you recall is your
reaction as you're listening to the
president say this the questions are the
answer
I remember thinking you know people
often write about how how I listened
when I'm doing interviews because anyone
who does interviews distance if they're
any sense but I mean and and I was
thinking this is this is the most
powerful example of that that you know
when we must not let a nuance pass as it
were in this not to interrupt him
because as Jack Brennan
said let him talk but but in terms of
not missing missing any opportunity and
then there's the and as he came through
to the the thing and when he said he had
said on the night that it before he he
said his farewell speech he had said to
and he quoted this that he said to his
friends and his group of friends he met
about six or seven o'clock and evening
I hope I haven't let you down
and at that point obviously they were
intended to sell also no of course not
mr. president another tall you've done a
wonderful job and very unfair you know I
mean that would have been it wasn't a a
genuine confession it was it was a
something to give a warm response but
then when in the interviews and he got
that point that he sent
I said I hope hadn't let you down well
that's it at all I had I'd let down the
hopes all them people and so on you know
but it was just that you expected to get
this from him fun how'd you expect it to
get this from Nick's head I think I
think we I think he went further than we
could really have ever seen really
seriously hoped now I'm a I'm an
optimist but in this particular case I
think I think he's he said everything
and more that one could have hoped every
weekend ceased